today it's clouds in some places Lonnie
Quinn chief weather caster tells us
where the best spots are here from WCBS
Lonnie well good morning everybody today
is the big day I mean everybody in this
country is gonna see some semblance of
this eclipse now most of us will catch
the penumbra and that's the shadow of
the moon but you'll still have a portion
of the Sun that's gonna be visible
throughout the entire thing but a select
view catch the Umbra and that is where
the moon totally blocks out the Sun day
will turn tonight that line stretches
from just outside of Portland Oregon
like Salem Oregon to Charleston South
Carolina and then if you're outside of
that area and now that line of totality
is about 70 miles wide but this gray
shaded area you'll see about 90% of the
Sun covered by the moon for Atlanta
Denver Seattle and then outside of that
area a very light gray shaded area
places like Philadelphia San Francisco
75% of your Sun is going to be covered
by the moon but as far as the weather it
looks pretty darn good for this eclipse
I think the two trouble spots would be
places like around Kansas City Missouri
I think too little too much cloud cover
for you I also think Charleston South
Carolina
you've got the cloud cover issue as well
but keep your eyes to the skies because
this could be a great show bill let's go
over to you all right Lonnie thanks so
much our two-hour special begins at 1:00
Eastern noon central right here on CBS